And she'll,
for an entirely nother universe.
I read this really cool book by physicists.
We talked about that,
that actually there might be entry point to different universe where the
cosmological constants are slightly different and just like genetic mutations,
which are different in every organism,
the Dm such that instead of having a big bang you would have actually had an
infinite number of universes constantly kind of creating and developing through
these different black hole portals makes actually more sense to me.
Well,
you know,
one of the things that I've always felt like when I have like really intense
psychedelic experiences,
like would it,
the thought that,
I mean a million people have is what if this is not actually an hallucination,
but in fact some sort of a chemical doorway into some other state.
There's something else out there and we're just so used to the idea that like
this chair sits on the ground and this table sits here and a laptop sits in a
chair and this is all normal,
but we could easily be from that DMT dimension.
That would be our normal everyday reality.
And they would come here and we would think this is the craziest fucking
psychedelic experience ever.
Drinking red liquid from thin glasses and talking into electrical impulses that
send them through wires.
And hundreds of thousands of people listen and they ride out of mass
transportation on fucking elliptical machines all over the world.
That is psychedelic,
that's psychedelic as fuck.
Well,
I mean,
that's,
if you lived in a dimension of pure love and,
and,
you know,
and eternal consciousness,
all interconnected.
And you know,
there was,
there was no physical matter.
You would just live in the DMT realm.
This world would be a completely.